it is a country used to being mobilized
against a common enemy and now that
unseen foe is the coronavirus an
outbreak could be devastating for a
population which is malnourished and
with primitive medical services those
populations in the countryside we are
they are really you know they have been
left on their own with regards to basic
accesses from the start it's taken tough
measures like closing its border with
neighboring China foreign diplomats were
put under a strict 30-day quarantine
which has only just been lifted many
have left and there is a certain tension
in the city in all over the country
because people are aware of state-run
television has been showing the global
impact of the disease and touting the
North's success in preventing a single
case of the virus as a victory for
leader Kim jong-un who's depicted as
heading his country's efforts Kim
jong-un has written to his South Korean
counterpart expressing his sadness for
the way the viruses hit the south and
while the outbreak has disrupted
military operations here with the
cancellation of joint exercises with the
US for North Korea it seems to be
business as usual twice in the space of
a week North Korea has conducted
short-range weapons tests after a lull
of three months some analysts say it's
just part of regular winter exercises
while others add that with
denuclearization talks in stalemate he
has nothing to lose by testing and that
it sends a strong message to his own
people that with much of the rest of the
world grappling with the viruses spread
Kim is firmly in control and appearing
to keep them safe Rob mcbride al Jazeera
Seoul